if this video was made possible by
Squarespace start building your website
for free at squarespace.com slash
Wendover and then when you're ready to
launch use the code Wendover for 10% off
if you were just dropped in this place
with no prior knowledge where would you
guess you were maybe Florida or
California or Hawaii somewhere tropical
but this is definitely the US it just
looks like the u.s. from the style of
signs to the way the roads look to the
stores that line the streets you can
tell it's the US but it's not Florida
it's not California it's not Hawaii it's
not even on this side of the world it's
America's most isolated territory
it's Guam the United States has five
inhabited territories the US Virgin
Islands Puerto Rico American Samoa the
Northern Mariana Islands and Guam itself
qualm is the farthest of these five from
the continental US nearly eight thousand
miles away from Washington DC making it
the most isolated Beijing deli Cape Town
and Buenos Aires are all closer to DC
than Guam is and yet the island is a
fully fledged territory of the US it is
the u.s. qualm has been inhabited for
thousands of years by the native
Chamorro people until the 1500s when it
was first claimed as a territory by
Spain
centuries later after the USA's victory
in the spanish-american war the
territory was ceded to the United States
along with Puerto Rico and the
Philippines aside from a brief and
brutal Japanese occupation during World
War two the island has remained part of
the US ever since
many Americans had never even heard of
Guam until summer 2017 that was when
North Korean leader Kim jong-un
threatened to launch a ballistic missile
at Guam the threats may have sent
subsided but the effects of that summer
have not the island stretches less than
30 miles from top to bottom which makes
it smaller than every other US state and
territory and yet it packs more than a
hundred and sixty thousand people into
that small size in fact it's more
densely populated than all but five US
states or territories meanwhile it is by
far the most developed place in
Micronesia to put it in perspective
Juan's neighboring islands the Northern
Mariana Islands which are also part of
the US
have a GDP per capita of $16,800 while
Guam's is more than $35,000 kiribati
meanwhile the most populous country in
Micronesia has a GDP per capita of
$1,500 Guam is now post of the modern
developed world in one of the poorest
regions of the world its location though
is its greatest assets its economy
exists because of where it is the island
is three hours from Tokyo four hours
from Seoul and five hours from Hongkong
it's close to Asia but it is still the
US unequivocally you see American
license plates american-style ambulances
they have u.s. post offices they use the
US dollar they have American stores
American hotels US national parks US
airlines there is no compromise on the
American Assam because it is the u.s.
they fly the US flag and for tourists
this is a draw instead of flying seven
hours to Hawaii or 10 hours to
California Japanese tourists can and do
just fly three hours to Guam in order to
visit the US the malls which look
identical to any in Virginia or Kansas
or anywhere else in the US are hugely
popular with Asian tourists as they can
buy American goods for a fraction of
what they would cost in Asia about 1.5
million people visit the island of a
hundred and sixty thousand each year but
what's not good for tourism is missile
threats last summer when they were
playing who's whose missiles bigger we
were the ones that suffered you go our
tourism took huge nosedive that month of
August we never saw so many news
agencies come into Guam and people from
countries that didn't even realize we
existed because all of a sudden Kim
jong-un was threatening the American
territory in the Pacific this is
Benjamin Cruz Speaker of the Guam
legislature as he said the islands
economy suffered immensely from the
North Korean missile threat many
visitors of Guam come as part of school
groups or corporate retreats and these
groups in particular almost universally
canceled their trips we lost
I mean almost our entire I mean probably
Japan stopped coming I mean everybody
was afraid to come the only ones that
were coming were the news me the news
media
fortunately the effects were partially
mitigated by an increase in visitors
from South Korea who were less worried
about missile threats since it's a
reality they live with every day back
home but for an island so centered
around tourism being dragged into
politics is never good
despite being part of the u.s. though
Guam functions politically differently
from every other part of the u.s.
Benjamin Cruz along with the 14 other
senators are the lawmakers of Guam they
can legislate just like any state
legislator but the main political
difference for Guam is at the federal
level all the u.s. federal laws the ones
made in Washington for the whole country
all those laws apply in Guam what Guam
doesn't get though is a vote their
congressional representatives don't get
a vote so by extension the people of
Guam can't vote on the laws that apply
to them in addition unlike Washington DC
which also doesn't receive a vote in
Congress Guam along with the other US
territories is not able to vote for
their president the u.s. president this
presents an issue not only because of
the lapse in democracy but also because
many US laws that may make sense for the
continental United States just don't for
a territory on the other side of the
world we'd like to be able to invite
people to the island and industries that
and not have to worry about whether or
not the SEC would approve it or the FCC
would approve it we'd like to be able to
have control over our skies so we can
invite Airlines to fly in without having
to clear with FAA on whether or not this
airline of that airline can or cannot
fly the process for a foreign airline of
gaining approval to fly to the u.s. is
often long and laborious and there are a
number of special security and
immigration rules for flights the u.s.
this isn't a problem for large
intercontinental airlines or Mexican or
Canadian wines for whom flights the US
represent a large part of their market
but for small regional Asian carriers
they might pass on flights to Guam just
to avoid having to gain FA
approval another issue for Guam is the
Jones Act this law prevents
foreign-built owned or operated ships
from carrying cargo or passengers
between US ports this may make sense
within the continental United States
just as you wouldn't want a foreign
airline flying domestic cargo routes you
wouldn't want a foreign shipping company
taking over cargo routes like Houston at
a Charleston or Seattle to Oakland but
Guam is a different story
cargo ships generally make many stops
along their routes so we'd be perfectly
normal for a Taiwanese ship for example
to go from Oakland to Hawaii took Guam
to a Saka to Taipei but it can't because
then it'd be transporting goods between
US ports instead only US ships can bring
goods from the US where most of guam's
goods come from to wong other US
territories like american samoa and the
northern mariana islands are exempt from
this rule but Guam is still subject to
it which makes shipping to the island
more expensive despite the issues the US
federal government may cause the people
of Guam are in no hurry to distance
themselves from it I think if you were
to ask a majority of the people of the
on the island they would like to have a
closer union with the United States and
someway even want statehood I mean in
fact a majority of them would would love
to see statehood in many ways Guam is
one of the most patriotic areas of the
US the US military free Guam from a
brutal and deadly Japanese occupation
during World War two which many of the
older residents still remember the
younger residents meanwhile quite often
work for the US just about every family
on this island I'm sure almost every
family on this island had at least one
member of their family served in the
military
one out of eight residents of Guam serve
or have served in the US Armed Forces it
has a higher enlistment rate than any
u.s. state but this is held by the fact
that 1/4 of the island is US military
bases the island is one of the u.s.
military's most strategic assets of
course the US has plenty of bases in
Japan and South Korea but Guam is US
soil less than four hours away from
North Korea the East China Sea and the
South China Sea all possible flash
points for u.s. conflict the US military
is the single largest employer on Guam
and his economy depends on the military
while tourism may have suffered recently
the military business is good the number
of military personnel stationed on Guam
is slated to more than double in the
coming decade which will no doubt
stimulate the economy this doesn't come
without concern Guam only has so much
land but all factors considered Guam is
on the rise
Guam is truly a unique place plenty of
countries have territories far away from
their mainland but few are as developed
and similar to the rest of the country
as Wang if Guam was just off the coast
of the US mainland it would be totally
unremarkable just another piece of the
u.s. that looks and acts like the rest
of the US but it's not it's on the other
side of the world qualms is a relic of
colonialism that today is a thriving
developed place it may not get treated
like the u.s. even by its own government
but in all other ways Guam is the United
States one aspect of Guam story that
this video didn't cover is how they're
trying to grow their local small
businesses in order to make the economy
more self-sustaining Squarespace also
helps with this they help small
businesses make what was previously only
available for huge companies a great
beautifully designed
professional-looking website small
businesses aren't necessarily physical
stores whatever you do whether it be
photography podcasting youtubing
anything you hope to make money from is
a business and so you need to make sure
people can find you if you're anything
like me the first place you go to find
something is the Internet so it's
absolutely crucial to have a great
looking website since that's your first
impression with their beautiful designer
templates customizable website builder
fantastic 24/7 customer support and
reasonable prices Squarespace is
absolutely the best place to build your
web presence best of all you can try out
Squarespace for free by going to
Squarespace comm slash Wendover and then
when you're ready to launch you can get
10% off only by using the code Wendover
at checkout
Squarespace is a great supporter of the
show and makes ambitious videos like
this which was filmed on location in
Guam possible so please do at least
check them out
at squarespace.com slash Wendover also
for those of you still here I want to
mention that there's a behind the scenes
video on my personal channel of Brian
from your legend earring Joseph from
real life lore and myself filming this
video on location in
thanks for watching and we'll see you
again in three weeks for another
Wendover productions video